red rock resorts talking about expanding
possibly into the southwest valley with
a new hotel and casino this coming on
the same day the corporation announcing
the sale of the palms joe mohler joining
us live with these tentative plans for
the future
joe well brian just take a look at these
buildings behind me here the development
and the growth in the southwest is hard
to miss and red rock resorts is taking
notice to that
they want to put their next project here
at the 215 and durango
and they want to break ground early next
year now they told investors
today that they didn't make as much
money in the first quarter of the year
due to
the pandemic but they are looking
forward to the rest of the year because
the first few months have been strong
more people are vaccinated and more
people feel comfortable going out
the ceo of the company says the sale of
the palms now allows them to focus on
neighborhood casino locations including
the one
at durango and the 215 in the future
the demographics are working to our
advantage given the migration that we're
seeing
from other states where people want to
avoid regulation
taxation and look to move to
a great state like nevada where there's
opportunity
area in the southwest valley does not
have a casino like this for several
miles so this location is key for red
rock resorts also known as station
casinos
the company will focus on a large casino
and several restaurants now back out
here live the development around this
spot
it's easy to spot if you just drive
around for a few blocks so
uh details surrounding this project this
casino and hotel here uh
details around it were not necessarily
released they expect to
release more about it in the next
earnings call in a couple months
reporting live in the southwest valley
joe mullen 8 news now